this is a common question I asked but it
usually ends up having great results and
that is of your IMDB credits which one
whether it was a short TV series
whatever which one taught you the most
and why without naming of course sure
object I feel like each one has taught
me and it's really from the people that
I worked with that I learned so one of
the things I feel like my first job I
worked for a producer I felt was a
master at cultivating interest in
projects um so he knew how to generate
interest and position and I learned in
cases where I might have missed out on a
project by not being assertive enough
and I say one project which I sold and
it was such a great high I was it was at
a time when I was told that it was at a
particular network that they had spent
their financing for the fiscal year and
we had an option on the book and it was
about to be up and that also it was a
period piece and I said we're not doing
period we're not doing period and I
won't saying but this reads to the
president of the production company this
wreath so hip the sweets so contemporary
most women today would die to do what
this girl did back then and I would my
boss actually said to me after that you
know be careful you shouldn't be so
boisterous you know with the president
anyway to make a long story short I
wound up speaking to the network to
where we had a deal and got the
president of the company and hurt VP's
all on board and they wound up optioning
the book and it was a series so there
were gonna be three books sadly there
was a regime change after we started the
process and we did get a first script
and the new regime decided that they
didn't want to do it again and that
happens in the business and it's
unfortunate but it is part of the
business and hopefully you just continue
to build on the six
and you're always going to have failures
you learn from your failures I mean that
case sometimes there are things outside
of one's control but what I learned
there was to have the courage of my
convictions I remember there was an
executive at the ABC who had said to his
group and they did really wonderful
programming if we're going to fail I
want us to fail big because we tried not
fail because we were scared and if you
look at any network and breakout shows
they were taking risks and going against
the grain and whether it was married
with children at the time x-files was on
there was nothing like that and then
everybody wanted to copy and do
something like x-files and the and I
remembered the sell of x-files was the
head of the network saying to Chris
Carter I just want you to do what you
really want to do so that was brave for
the executive in hindsight we can all
say that's fine but he was really
encouraging the pure voice and
creativity of that particular writer and
boy when you you know can follow your
vision and your passion and you have
combined with the talent to deliver and
the support and the right studio behind
you can really deliver something that's
iconic and you you know becomes part of
the our pop culture and everything the
going back to the so what I had learned
so I really felt strongly because of
that reward that I would always follow
the courage of my convictions so I think
it's really important to do that with
other movies I would say I learned from
a really intelligent boss writer
director who's no longer with us that
just not to have a lazy mind and never
go for the easy solution he was great at
with development and when what other
stories we had and I learned so much
from him was to really look at the
authenticity of how a character would
behave and not just go for the obvious
he's
generic solution so that really taught
me I think to be diligent and try and
find the unexpected behavior in
characters and so anyway - I could be
here for a long time but I have I've
learned from really I think our greatest
teachers are working with other people
who who are good at what they do
you